I know you've been dealing with my
husband but as i'm sure you've heard
he's gone so now you're dealing with me
i recognize that you like to get down to business
i respect that i'd like to offer my condolences
to you and your daughter but your husband made
a mess of things and now you're going to clean
it up i'm not going to do this forever you
don't have to you do it until it's done
the bad news is that your father had to work
a little and couldn't pick you up good news
that means that i can take you
to have some ice cream ice cream
you talk about organized crime in the marvel
universe and you talk about the cd underbelly
of new york city there is one primary character
that comes to mind he said i want to bring you
into the mcu and i'm not going to say no to that
like that's pretty awesome i really loved playing
this character i liked creating him you know from
the art of guys like david mack fisk is really
driven by emotion you know he's like a child and
a monster both at the same time so it got very
intense yesterday and got a little bit intense
today too
Welcome back everyone this will be my
marvel hawkeye kingpin deleted scenes video for
all the scenes of kingpin that hit the cutting
room floor and there's a lot of them vincent
d'onofrio kevin feige explain why they chose to bring
him back from the daredevil netflix series just
like they brought charlie cox back as matt murdock
daredevil inspired me in no way home there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs if you're brand new
to the channel i'll be doing full episode videos
for marvel's moon knight series just like i did for
hawkeye that's going to start pretty soon be sure
to subscribe to get all those but as they explain
here it was actually kevin feige's idea to bring
back vincent d'onofrio from the daredevil netflix
series just like it was his idea to bring back the
original green goblin norman osborne other tobey
maguire andrew garfield sinister six villains
in spider-man no way home like tobey maguire and
andrew garfield themselves and i'm sure the same
will probably be true when patrick stewart finally
explains why he came back as professor x and
doctor strange multiverse of madness in any other
x-men and fantastic four characters from the fox
marvel movies that we learned about in the film
and it is really cool to hear vincent dinovio talk
about how precious the wilson fisk character is to
him notice that he always calls him wilson fisk he
doesn't call himself the kingpin when he's talking
about his character this is just the beginning too
if it wasn't clear he did not die at the end of
the hawkeye finale he is still alive but the first
big deleted scene is a flashback of kate bishop's
mother eleanor having a dinner meeting with the
kingpin right after the events of the avengers
movie in the battle of new york notice that he's
wearing the same black outfit that he wore in the
early daredevil netflix episodes before he
started wearing the white suit that didn't
come till daredevil season 3. that's because the
events of daredevil season 1 happen relatively
soon after the events of the battle of new york
so while this is happening in the background you
have to imagine daredevil's out there running
around beating up criminals in hell's kitchen
i also believe this is happening before
the events of the daredevil season 1 finale
when kingpin got hauled to prison the two
of them talk about the arrangement that
kate bishop's father made with kingpin the debt
that he's in that eleanor is going to help repay
through the bishops security business they kind
of hinted at the connection between kate's father
derek and kingpin during episode one but they
never actually said his name out loud or anything
about the mob in that episode you just hear her
mother arguing with him about how they're gonna
make ends meet because they don't have any money
and he said he'd found a way to take care of it
turns out that way was kingpin by episode 6 when
kingpin meets with her they fill in the rest of
that backstory and this deleted scene just fills
in even more of that basically them discussing
the terms of the actual deal and how she's going
to repay that debt but if it wasn't clear kate's
father took out a huge loan from kingpin and
originally before he died during the battle
of new york he was going to be the one running
bishop security probably with help from kate's
mother so all the shady stuff that kate's mother
has been doing the past several years for kingpin
that would have been her father doing all that
stuff for him and if it wasn't clear from the
super illegal tracking software their company
had on kate's phone that she was able to use
to track people they were using bishop security
to do a bunch of different things for kingpin
one they served as a money laundering operation
pretty boilerplate if you're tied to the mob
that's like pretty standard stuff two they were
also a front company for the tracksuit mafia bros
who were controlled by the kingpin and he just
used them to steal all kinds of precious artifacts
and valuables and it's just general muscle around
the new york city area and three because of their
security tracking software systems they had
cameras all over the city kingpin also used
them for information gathering which sometimes
can be more valuable than actual physical
items that they were stealing like the watch in
episode 1. also if it wasn't clear why kingpin
wanted that watch so badly we learned in the
finale that the watch belonged to hawkeye's
wife the shield logo in the number 19 on the back
confirmed that this whole time in the mcu we've
been watching her his wife has secretly been a
version of bobby morse mockingbird as an agent 19.
even though this whole time they've been calling
her laura like hawkeye has been calling her laura
my assumption is that originally when they created
the character for avengers age of ultron when they
wanted to do hawkeye's backstory on this farm here
they didn't plan for her to be mockingbird in the
hawkeye people with kevin feige in present day
decided to retcon that into her backstory i think
there was also supposed to be some extra storyline
for hawkeye's wife that would have explained that
a little bit more but it sounds like they wound
up deleting that out too there were a couple big
subplots that they did and then wound up deleting
at the last minute from the hawkeye series
but kingpin wanted the watch because he was really
after ronan and he could use the watch to connect
things back to hawkeye's family on the farm but
that first deleted scene where kingpin and kate's
mother are agreeing about the terms of their deal
she's only going to work for him until the debt
is repaid is meant to connect to that scene in
episode six where she says she's more than repaid
the debt and she wants out so i'm assuming this
flashback would have happened at the beginning of
episode six the second kingpin deleted scene
is another flashback of kingpin just being
uncle kingpin for young maya lopez at her martial
arts class and i believe this would have also been
part of episode 3 when they're doing the speed
run version of ekko's backstory there's also
another separate deleted scene of young maya
at this same martial arts class with young
quasi setting up their friendship at a young age
i think to help pay off the betrayal in the finale
there were a lot of other echo deleted scenes from
the finale and other episodes so it sounds like
they shot a ton of echo storylines setting her
character up for the spin-off series that wound up
hitting the cutting room floor so if you felt like
ekko was kind of an underdeveloped character in
the series they actually did film a huge storyline
for her the funny thing about the hawkeye series
too is it is actually the first marvel disney
plus series that they've actually legit released
deleted scenes for whole cloth like there were a
ton of deleted scenes for loki wandavision falcon
and winter soldier i've done videos for all of
them so i'll post links for some of those deleted
scenes videos in the description below but hawkeye
is the first time that marvel has officially quote
unquote officially released the deleted scenes
online they should do that more often because
they are really cool but the whole idea here with
this kingpin echo deleted scene is just setting
up their relationship so that the betrayal stings
way harder when she learns about it in the finale
and the payoff is way bigger when she winds up
shooting him but not killing him remember he's not
dead he's coming back i think the main reason they
cut these extra kingpin scenes is because they
didn't want to fully reveal kingpin all the way
back in episode 3 for the echo backstory like we
all knew that it was kingpin when he reached his
handout to touch her face and if they'd revealed
kingpin and even elena bulova early on because we
knew that she was going to be part of the series
as well because of that black widow post-credit
scene everyone would have just been talking about
kingpin daredevil and elena bolova's stuff and if
we just stolen all the juice from the kate bishop
story line like yeah yeah kate bishop this is all
cool but show us more kingpin stuff more daredevil
stuff more elena bulova and the big thing with
the hawkeye series is that it was mostly supposed
to be a bookend for clint barton after avengers
end game in setting up the whole kate bishop mcu
storyline it's kind of like grogu and mandalorian
coming to the book of boafet and taking over that
series halfway through everyone's like yeah yeah
boba fett he's real cool love what you're doing
here but we really want to see what's going on
with grogu's jedi training story line with luke
skywalker and what's going on with mando and
the darksaber i've done a couple other videos
about what marvel's plans are for the daredevil
characters in the mcu going forward there's going
to be a lot more daredevil coming soon especially
in some of the other marvel disney plus series so
i'll link those videos below in the description
too i feel so lucky to have been cast in that role
and it and it is the gift that keeps on giving
i loved every single minute of making the show
but so to be honest to come back um and to be
involved in any capacity is absolutely thrilling
to me and i hope you know i don't want to sound
greedy but i hope i get to do loads more i hope i
get to be involved way way more for many years
i hope it never ends being in the mcu allows
that we couldn't really do in the with the netflix
stuff is that i can now interact with other mcu
characters crossovers would be really is the thing
i would like to do next there are some really
interesting stories there that i would like to i'd
love for the character to explore if you spotted
any other big easter eggs in these deleted scenes
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
them below in the comments there's rumors they're
going to be releasing an extended director's cut
of spider-man no way home at some point in the
next couple weeks with a bunch of extra daredevil
and tobey maguire andrew garfield scenes if that
winds up happening i'll do a video for that too
while you wait for everything everyone click here
for my brand new doctor strange multiverse of
madness trailer video easter eggs and click
here for my marvel moon knight trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!